it's completely shifted my attitude
towards islam before i just thought this
is a false religion now i'm like oh no
this is a tool of satan this is a tool
of satan and the people who are
following it are unknowingly
soldiers of the devil
of the highest degree right he's strong
some of his strongest foot soldiers god
made a religion it's christianity
the devil made a religion it's called
islam
didn't know that the prophet muhammed
the person who invented a religion
nine-year-old girl
this is a fact he married a girl at six
years old and then consummated the
marriage at nine that is rape and the
reason why it doesn't phase the average
muslim when you bring that up to them is
because jesus is not in their heart it's
because the holy spirit god is not in
their heart young don if you see this
somebody clips and send this to you i
hope you're going to be fair and honest
and and open enough that when i give the
references from the bible you're going
to go and look them up and if you're
going to make any kind of accusations
against islam and the prophet of islam
the prophet muhammad peace and blessings
be upon him then i hope that you will
make the same exact words against other
traditions when i bring them up
otherwise your sincerity will be known
to everybody uh talking about pedophilia
i'm gonna bring up something from his
bible and i know he feels he doesn't
need to defend his bible but he needs to
at least defend his statements now right
they're going to want to hear this one
they're definitely going to want to hear
this one listen i want to give a quick
disclaimer right now this is not an
enticement of violence harassment
bullying
threats we don't want to hear out that
you know because of you guys we did this
to don or we send him this message we
don't want to get any of this smoke
listen the reality is john if you're
watching this we just have a question
for you you've been going on streams on
your channel every single day click on
it
you have a title that doesn't have
anything to do with islam so it shows
you started the stream with the
intention of talking about something
and then eventually you start talking
about about islam and then two hours
later it's deleted
like i don't understand this bro like if
you're going to say it why are you
deleting it you know but
unfortunately you have to you know ask
for this smoke so
man is going to deliver today inshallah
look before we even start i just want to
say we want good for you don in case you
watch this or somebody send you the clip
but we want good for you
we want you to be guided towards the
truth we want you to follow what is
truth and we we feel that you are
sincere
in the fact that you do want to find the
truth but maybe
the way you're going about it is
incorrect instead of having a discussion
face to face instead of talking it
through just making streams and watching
islamophobes by the way all those people
that you watched and you talk about
watching i've already debated them face
to face and you can go watch those
debates on the one message foundation
channel you can see how they fell apart
if you really want to know the truth
we're inviting you right now jump on
even if you want to come in during the
half the show and we'll have a civil
conversation with evidences with
references that you can look up bring
your references if you want to bring in
your little friends apis or mr
hammertime earning them bring them we're
right here live bring it
christianity and islam which is of the
devil
and you can see it in the behaviors
after the fact if i went on that stream
and i had talked with all those muslims
and you know and i didn't know anything
about islam i didn't know that the
prophet muhammed the person who invented
the religion nine year old girl
this is a fact he married a girl at six
years old and then consummated the
marriage at nine that is rape anybody
that wants to try and tell me that a
nine-year-old girl can have consensual
sex with a 53 year old man you're sick
or they're just so deluded and the
reason why it doesn't phase the average
muslim when you bring that up to them is
because jesus is not in their heart it's
because the holy spirit god is not in
their heart to strengthen that morale
how do you hear this
and try to look past it or rationalize
that the man the the quran see i learned
a lot about islam after the fact you
know what i mean what after the call
after yeah because i went into it
looking thinking that i was about to
learn about islam but in them you know
coming for me i had to now go and learn
about it on my own terms let me talk
about rape i don't know where the idea
of rape came from but let's talk about
marriage and let's talk about the age of
none of us are
mentally present at the time of birth
none of us notice hey you're born and
you're like hey i'm born today what's
the time what's the date right
if we ask anyone here when you were born
you're going to look at a birth
certificate you're going to look at your
passport you're going to go ask your mom
you don't remember right so you're
basically taking information from other
sources and if those sources have some
ambiguity then you're going to pass that
on
arabs had no calendar understand this
that the arabs had no calendar i don't
mean that they didn't have a lunar
assault they had no calendar basically
they would have events like amil feel
the year when abraham attacked makkah
the elephant and they would kind of give
it a name from an event or a drought or
a flood or a lot of rain and they would
give it a name and they would try to
map ages from that and that's why not
just discussing eyes
even
huh the first wife of the prophet
alaihis salaam who by the way as long as
he was married to he didn't marry any
other woman
she passed away and then he married the
woman after that but until she was alive
she was his only wife
even her age disputed why because again
the autumns were not concerned about
recording your birthday
most of the early scholars also we know
their death dates we don't know their
birthday for the early scholars of islam
and the sahaba and so on some of them we
have ideas because if they have major
uh events that happened that year like
the year of the field ahmed field of the
elephant with the year the prophet
muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
was born and because of that major event
we know but if people were born in years
where they weren't major events then
it's very hard to know their exact age
what we can say about
that her age was appropriate for the
time for marriage and how do we know
that that she was already engaged to
jubeir ibn mutherim before she was even
engaged i'm not talking about marriage
talking about engagement to the prophet
muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
for us to judge that age today is what's
called presentism this is this is not
fair it's not uh appropriate why
um rami if you can on your screen
bring up safari google chrome i don't
really care look up average life expense
expectancy sixth century
yeah
and for anyone that didn't hear that
that's the logical fallacy of presentism
okay 30 to 35. 30 to 35 years old
think about that this is the sixth
century this is when the prophet isaiah
was born this is the time we're looking
at
in that time period your average life
expenses it was 30-35 today it's about
77 years of age in hong kong in japan
it's around 80.
okay
so today when we talk about the age of
marriage being 18 that would not be
practical for that time today when we
talk about oh
he's too young to get married she's too
young to get married what do we talk
about they haven't finished their
schooling
right she didn't finish high school she
didn't finish college he didn't get a
degree yet
understand in those times you didn't
have any of that so when a girl was
physically mature when when the
biological indicators were there for
example she got her period or you know
other signs that show maturity they
would get married because nature would
tell them you are now physically ready
to get married and that was very common
they didn't have school to go to they
didn't have med school they didn't have
any of this they didn't you know this is
what they did men at the time when they
were physically capable would go out and
work they would do trade they would go
plant seeds uh you know they would farm
today if we take a 12 year old and put
them to work people say this is
child labor laws you know this is
abusing children
you're taking advantage of the child
because he should finish his schooling
but that would mean the whole world was
abusing children at the time because
everybody when they were physically old
enough 12 13 14 years of age they would
go out and work right so this is this is
a fallacy this is something that is not
correct and anybody with a bit of logic
would understand this right
at that time this was that regular way
or age to get married
but
if we have uh mr young
don
talking about pedophilia
i'm gonna bring up something from his
bible and i know he feels he doesn't
need to defend his bible but he needs to
at least defend his statements now right
um if you don't mind rami can you bring
up the first screenshot that i sent you
100
excellent so
i'm going to give you guys some bible
verses and i'm going to leave the
screenshot there and i want to discuss
it in a minute
but i want everybody to write down these
verses as well so they can keep this as
a record
if we look in the bible the bible that
mr don claims to believe in that he's
promoting that christians
hand out to us that give out that you go
to hotels and you find it in their
drawers
in genesis 17 17 we find and if one of
you guys can take some notes here as
well
that sarah was 90 when abraham was 100.
ibrahimo
right so sarah was how old she was 90
when ibrahim abraham was 100 according
to genesis 17 17.
you got me
okay
now in general sorry just yeah so i have
i have three links
i have the um
just
just the first link just leave it there
um it's a commentary and we're not gonna
i'm gonna get to that in a minute okay
but first i just want you guys to write
these ages or remember them okay
genesis 17 17 in the bible again i want
to make a point the age of
is not in the quran the prophet didn't
tell us we do know from
hadith and think we have no problem with
that
but this i'm giving you from the bible
itself
from their text their holy text okay
sarah was 90 abraham was 100 genesis 17
17. in genesis 21 5
abraham was 100
ishaq or isaac was born
okay
in genesis 23 1 and 2 in the beginning
we find that sarah died at the age of
127. stay with me you can watch this
recording again later if you want to
really get this down
isaac is hawk was 40 when he married
rebecca according to the bible look
genesis
25 20.
explicit he was 40 years old when he
married rebecca
sarah was 90 when isaac was born
according to the bible when isaqah islam
was born sarah was 90 years old
that's a conclusion you can take from
one and two from sarah being 90 when
abraham was 100 and abram being 100 when
isaac was born so she was
here now is fine that she was 90 when
isaac was born
now
isaac or his hawk was 37 when his mother
sarah died
okay look at that if you take 127
subtract 90 from it you get 37.
and it's hard being 37 at his mother's
death
and he was 37 when rebecca was born
because rebecca was born when sarah died
so isaac was 40 according to this when
he married rebecca who was three years
old
so one more time 40 year old rebecca at
three years old
and again according because i'm a muslim
because i'm a muslim they might be like
oh you're trying to misread our text and
that's why rami has now brought up a
screenshot
and this one i'm going to discuss this
is a you have the
aramaic or the hebrew text right there
this is a commentary on the old
testament or the torah by rabbi basha
ibn ashir
and this here if you look at the
scroll down you will find that he
clearly saves and this is a jewish
classic
accepted commentary uh very early on
um this is not something you know we've
come up with recently uh this was i
think written uh the rabbi uh review was
uh i think around
12 55 to 13 40. this is any a few
hundred years old classic well and this
website is a jewish website it's not a
muslim website
so what does he say based on biblical
text he says and it's very clear it says
the torah itself testifies that yitzhak
i mean
was 40 years old when he married
which is rebecca
who which
makes rebecca three years old when she
was married
you can you highlight that on your
screen so people can see yeah actually
it's been highlighted for the last like
two minutes three minutes maybe
on the bottom of that screenshot while
you're screen sharing
that's okay i don't think so as long as
everybody else can see it okay so now we
want to be very very explicit here that
jesus rabbis biblical scholars in
accepted well-known biblical
commentaries that are right now on
jewish websites and we're talking about
the old testament which again as
christians are supposed to believe in
when they give us the bible it's not
just the new testament they have the old
testament there they believe that this
is the same god that they worship jesus
was the same god of the old testament so
that means according to their bible
isaac
40 year old married a three-year-old and
this is the works of their god and this
is not just
a biblical incident i'm gonna now take
you to the second
uh
link that i sent to you rami if you can
bring that up okay
and it's loading in okay so we got
genesis 25 22.
excellent so now this is from the old
testament part of the bible and it
clearly mentions here
um if we go down
that
isaac was
40. and
bring it up here
here
genesis 25 20. isaac was 40 years old
when he took wife rebecca
now if you look on the right hand side
you will find the commentary from rashi
rashi
is a
standard well-known commentary used for
biblical uh references it was uh written
by rabbi solomon ibn zak and he is 1040
to 1106. very classic it's commonly
known as rashi
and this is as you can read in the
introduction this is the single most
influential jewish biblical commentary
of the middle ages
anybody who studied judaism anybody
who's christians that have studied the
old testament know that this is a
standard this is the well-known accepted
commentary from the middle ages what
does rashi say
he says when abraham came from mount
moriah he received the news rebecca was
born and he gives the reference 22 20.
isaac was 37 years old because at that
time sarah died from the birth of isaac
until the binding
when sarah died there was 37 years since
she was 90 years old when isaac was born
and 127 years old when she died
as it is said in 2031 he's giving all
the biblical references here and the
life of sarah was 127 years
thus isaac was then 37 years old at the
period rebecca was born and he waited
until she was now pay attention to this
until she was fit for marriage which was
three years
and then married her
according to the bible the age that a
girl is fit for marriage is three years
of age and this is not a muslim
commentary this is not me trying to
interpret their texts this is their own
scholars in their own commentaries using
their own bible
okay
now three years old
three years old is the age for marriage
right according to them not us not as
muslims right if you want to talk about
pedophilia let's talk about pedophilia
right but we'll get to it we'll get to
the new testament too relax all the
christians that are jumping up and down
you guys claim you believe in the old
testament it's part of the bible that
you give you claim it's the same god so
you believe in this okay
now if you can go to the third link i
sent you
all right
third link
yeah
all right it's looking like
uh
541 dr joshua culp
this is the talmud
this is the commentaries of the jewish
rabbis that based their rulings off of
the bible of the old testament right of
the of the torah
and here
in the explanation of it it mentions
in the talmud itself
this is jewish law
a girl of the age of three years and one
day if you're more than three years if
you're a day more maybe be thought by
intercourse if uh jalam had intercourse
with her he acquires her thereby this is
old testament law okay what does that
mean that if a girl is one day more than
three years of age and somebody has sex
whether it's forcefully or not
he is now her husband she will be
betrayed to him as it is as stated above
intercourse with a girl over the age of
three years counts as intercourse
therefore since withdrawal may be
performed by intercourse she may be
betrayed in this way if she is
liable for yabon meaning a previous
husband which i don't know how a
three-year-old could have a previous
husband but
and the yam her dead husband's brother
had intercourse with her she becomes his
wife
at three years of age
read this this again look at the website
that's why i shared the link i'm not
just reading it so people can go look it
up this is not us as muslims coming in
so if you want to take shots don come
let's talk about it right let's bring up
your bible right we'll get to it
now
again
this means intercourse uh he creates
legal obligation legal relationship
and
who is liable for adultery with her it
says her father who marries her off to
someone else
understanding that according to jewish
law a girl
who is a katana this is a kitana this is
a word that's used in their law
according to the old testament
at between the age of 3 and 12
can be given in marriage even without
her consent
by her father
right because this is the legal age of
marriage between 3 and 12
according to old testament laws right
now i know we're going to get some fun
christians that are going to say oh you
know this the old testament or new
testament
okay
first thing as i've clearly mentioned
repeatedly now um
the bible that you guys give out as
christians contains the old testament
you do believe in it supposedly right so
this is all applicable to you but let's
talk about jesus and mary and joseph
the earliest document that i could find
that discusses the age of joseph i'm not
talking about people today trying to
rewrite history the earliest that i can
find is from the sixth and seventh
centuries which is a book called the
history of joseph the carpenter um
and here uh robinge motomir
probably mispronouncing that european um
says in the book in the history of
joseph the carpenter that
if you look at early church
fathers and their writing early
evangelical church
that they believe that joseph was 90
years of age look up the book yourself
look again don
if you watch this or any other christian
go get the book you can get on amazon
the history of joseph the carpenter look
it up yourself right what do they say
they say that joseph was 90 years of age
and mary was 12.
how old was she
12.
so now catholics you call saint joseph
christians you call him a great
personality in the biblical structure
the stepfather of god according to you
guys right uh you know one of the first
believers that he defended mary all of
us right you're gonna call him pedophile
let's let's see let's you live by what
you say
because if a 90 year old marries a 12
year old today that's what you would
call them
but right now you're going to be like oh
no no no this is this is not in the
bible itself well the age of
the united states
if you're going to go with historic
reports then we're going to use your
historic reports that tell us that
joseph was 90 marrying a 12 year old now
i'm going to mention something just for
dawn a little fun thing because he
mentioned an author during our stream
what was the author do you guys remember
john mccarthy macarthur right john
mccarthy
john mcarthur was the one that don
brought up
right not me not you he brought it home
well i have a lot of his books i have
his biblical commentary i also have a
book it's called god in the manager
and the miraculous birth of christ
in which
john macarthur
the one that don brought up says that
that mary was likely engaged to joseph
when she was between 12 and 13 years of
age
so
there is no getting out of this dawn
your own john macarthur says he was 12
years old 12-13 right the earliest
scriptures that you have the catholic
encyclopedia i don't care if you're not
catholic just because i've given
christian references protestant
references i'm going to give catholic
references they also mention that
that according to them uh joseph when he
was 40 he had married another woman and
i'm going to read from this um this is
before his marriage to mary when he was
40 years of age joseph married a woman
called milcha or ischa assam
salaam by others
then lived 49 years together and had six
children two daughters and four sons the
youngest of them was james which is
mentioned in the bible james
the less the lord's brother they say
a year after his wife's death as the
priests announced through judea that
this they wished to find in the tribe of
judah a respectable man to spouse mary
then 12 to 14 again 12 to 14 years of
age at the time
years of age and joseph was 90 years old
this is not just one reference it's not
just christians it's not just catholics
it's the earliest references and the
current and john macarthur himself gives
her age at 12. here again she's 12 and
he's how old
90 years old when he went up to
jerusalem amongst the candidates and a
miracle manifested in the choice of god
had made joseph and the truth is god's
will that he was doing and two years
later uh anyway so now
just to give you a couple of references
there's not like some you know
obscure reference that i found bernard
fontana he also mentioned that mary was
12 and joseph was 90. these are the
well-respected christian authors and
scholars that they put out there um in
charles talbert's commentary on the new
testament this is a new testament on
matthew he also says that did mary have
sexual relations with joseph because
they might be like oh joseph didn't have
relations with her he clearly says he
goes mary had sexual relations because
in the bible in matthew it states that
mary did not have sexual relations with
joseph until after jesus birth
so he says from amongst the early
witnesses we find that mary did have a
sexual relationship with joseph after
the birth of jesus according to
christian scholars
um tony coffee he says that matthew had
stated that joseph had no sexual
relationship very until she gave birth
to a son
this tells us that after jesus birth
joseph
who was past 90 at this time and mary
who was around 13 past 12 years of age
had normal sexual relations like any
other couple tony coffee right
so
what does that tell us
if don and any other christian is going
to be sincere and honest and be straight
up about it then i want them to go in
and tell us why joseph was about
why uh isaac was a pedophile why all
these biblical references
tell tell them and when they come back
and say oh no no no at that time when
mary was betrayal that was the average
age when people got married then the
same is true for ayesha
right
in fact the age gap between joseph and
marriage is much more than that of
between the prophet muhammad sallam
and the age gap between isaac and
rebecca in the bible is also much more
than that which is between the prophet
muhammad
so
we come at it straight there's no
ambiguity here we're coming out with
evidences with biblical verses with
books that references and if they're
honest sincere even right now if they
jump on i'm here i'm ready to take a
face-to-face conversation with anybody
who wants to do it
just to quickly interject a lot of
people are commenting this what's the
age of majority in islam and from what i
know the age of majority is
that you are mature that's it the age of
maturity not majority age of maturity is
that you are mature now correct me if
i'm wrong so
in islam we discussed this issue of bulu
of who becomes balik and there are many
different sides
signs between a man and a woman that
shows when they are physically mature um
one of them is for a woman for example
if she gets her head if she gets her
period um for a man and there is certain
hair that grows in certain places
certain dreams certain things that we
look at to know whether they are bali
but that also doesn't mean that they're
ready for marriage
because as the
books discuss that marriage is done when
somebody is physically capable and able
for marriage and
many of the commentaries then also talk
about a mental state right
so what does that mean
a girl may be at a age where her period
doesn't come because in her culture or
her environment the period comes very
late or some that come very early but
she may not be physically ready for
marriage so at that time we would not
allow that to be an islamic marriage
islam looks at what we call our means
the local customs and traditions look at
merge age right meaning that if uh for
example in a country where there is no
education system there's no schooling um
the average life like expectancies are
very low and people get married early as
long as the woman is physically ready
naturals indicators of marriage and the
man is physically ready then they could
get married in other cultures if there
is a delayed period meaning the people
are going to school they have things and
they want to wait till they're older
nothing wrong with that we look at the
earth there we don't allow marriage
until somebody has the natural
indicators of marriage we don't give a
age because if we said 10
not every 10 year old is the same
everywhere else right in america for
example the legal age for marriage and
many states used to be 10 years of age
and now they've bumped it up to 16 and
some states 18 but most states still at
around 16. some are still i think that
14 you can look it up
why because time
and locations differ till today in
africa there are countries where the
lifespans are very low education does
not exist in and women regularly get
married at 10 and 12 years of age and we
sitting in america to say that's wrong
is very
hypocritical of us because even in
america that used to be the fact
and i'll say one more thing
one of the hypocrisies of western
society is when they talk about child
marriages they don't talk about sex of
under eight children
we have middle school kids that are
pregnant right
i went to a school that had a daycare i
mean and this was my middle school in
san diego um because so many girls had
already especially if you look at the
latina community so many girls had
already had children
i have i have people that i went to
school with that at 12 and 13 got
pregnant meaning they were already
having sex before that so somebody is
old enough to be having sex why aren't
old enough to get married you know this
is something that we find as a hypocrisy
in western society because at age 18 for
example where did we come up with that
number you know some people at 18 may
not physically be ready for marriage
some people at 18 maybe some people at
16 may be ready you know so in islam we
don't go by just putting a arbitrary
number we look at first and foremost the
natural indicators of the body if a
woman has her period if a man has
certain natural indicators that won't
get into detail here but in our fifth we
discuss it
then
we say that they are naturally
the nature of the person shows that they
are ready for sexual intercourse and
ready for marriage that doesn't mean
they should get married at that age they
may not be mentally prepared they don't
have to islam doesn't say it right when
that happens get married no
but if they are mentally
mature and in the earth in the tradition
of their land they can't then they
should right so this is the islamic
rulings
all
right
one thing i want to say is uh you can
turn your mic up on your end most likely
uh secondly i think that's
echo for a second but my my gain is the
highest price oh i see i see okay i know
where's inshallah alright so we'll do it
afterwards okay
i think that was clear for everyone one
thing i want to add is um just a little
note uh
once i heard it never left my mind in
california there is no minimum age
requirement with parental consent so if
aisha was alive today or anyone nowadays
they could legally get married with
parental consent which she had aisha
in california today
if you have a problem with that
go to the county file some kind of
complaint
talk to your political representative
and throw your tantrums there don maybe
he lives in cali himself i don't know
throw your tantrums there go to the
county and complain
and again i mean even if you look at uh
age of consent or age of marriage today
that's all arbitrary we're just making
up numbers to be honest right because if
you look at like i said if your life
expense expectancy is between 30 and 35
you can't expect somebody to wait till
they're 20 years old to have their first
child right they won't even be you know
10 15 years old their parents will be
dead right so how do you raise children
that way and if you have no schooling
system what do you do i mean once you're
bald when you're when you're mature when
you're physically natural indicators
show that you're ready for marriage
you're just going to sit around wait 10
years for what you know so so that's
that's the whole point that people are
looking at this all wrong
but again and inshallah i'm going to
jump off and let you guys continue
having your fun but uh we have a
conference i gotta get to here but uh i
i will again leave with a couple of
summary points one
regarding the age of aye star diana no
doubt that she was at an appropriate age
of marriage for that time period because
none of the mushrikeen the polity is
ever objected to her marriage her
parents didn't object to her marriage
nobody else in that society until the
1900s western
academics didn't object to that marriage
because their own kings and in my video
that i have about the age of
i show western kings and queens that got
married at much younger ages than ayesha
and this was in the 16th century in 17th
century not the sixth
right so uh the hypocrisy of gone and
others in the west
it's mind-blowing right
secondly
if you're gonna throw some kind of
statements out there then i want you to
go back and look at the bible and i want
you to look at the reference that i gave
and i want you to look at those
commentaries and i want you to look at
those reference to the age of joseph in
the age of mary and then i want you to
use the same standard be fair and
balanced and use the same standard in
what you're talking about
and lastly i want to go back to this
that none of this has to do with
credible issues
none of this has to do with aqedah this
is just somebody who was on a live
stream got caught and showing that the
bible shows that jesus didn't know the
hour he didn't know knowledge that the
father knew so now he can't be co-equal
because he doesn't know and your creedal
issues fall apart the death of judas
falls apart the the clear contradictions
in the bible show that what you're
basing your salvation on
is a book that has been flawed has been
changed and edited and has clear numeric
contradictions your own author that you
mentioned john macarthur says that there
are copies errors in the bible and now
that your
base of your creed and your belief and
your book fell apart you're looking for
excuses to take shots
i want you to go back to creedal issues
and go back to understanding and use a
fair and balanced way and if you want to
jump on with us another time insha'allah
i'll be more than willing to come back
and have a conversation directly uh with
don or anybody else inshaallah inshallah
all right so you guys
heard it here saw it here first very
clear
very like it's kata bro it's clear cut
there is no way out don all you can do
now is be fair say that you are on an
emotional high
and apologize for your blatant
statements or make the same statements
about christianity and at the end of the
day
know that you actually have achieved
nothing
for christianity you have achieved
nothing for christianity and actually
even nothing against islam
[Music]
the prophet saw mentioned that the
bridge between belief and disbelief is
abandoning salah if you're struggling
with your salah right now well we got
the perfect solution for you and that
solution is the adan app this cell phone
we usually have it and it's using us
instead of us using it but with the adan
app you can use it in perfect alignment
with your life the adhan app is already
used by 40 million believers around the
world why because it caters to your
islamic lifestyle on top of the salah
times you get their eyes
the islamic calendar ramadan calendar
suhur and iftar times
hajj and umrah guide qibla finder and
much more for free so download the
adonab now